[Music]
Adam is with us in st. Louis hi Adam
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show better
than I deserve what's up kind of lost
I've been listening to you for about
eight months now so I have a general
idea of how to do things but I also
don't my son has stage three t-cell
lymphoblastic lymphoma and because of
his cancer battle my $30,000 and that is
still appearing it's still going up and
I looking for advice on how to target
work on where I'm at plus be able to
handle the incoming bills as his medical
okay so you got $30,000 in debt now and
what's his prognosis how's he doing it's
curable but it's good be about a two and
a half year recovery mmm okay and how
far into this two and are you two and a
half years from now two and a half years
from now we're about a year and a half n
okay you have two and a half more years
to go correct
okay and what's your household income
bringing about 37 a year Wow and you
currently have $30,000 in outstanding
medical bills correct that insurance did
not cover that the insurance did not
cover okay I have horrible insurance
through my work unfortunately
okay and so well the the first goal is
for your family to eat and we take care
of your son long before we worry about
paying back medical bills okay the
second goal is to develop a plan to keep
his treatments going and not get behind
any further right and so what do you
know what your ongoing bills are going
to look like from this point forward
right now I know that just some of his
medications
that he has to take regularly is 950
dollars a month's okay and that's not
covered that is not covered okay and
have you been in touch with that drug
company to tell them that you make
thirty seven thousand dollars a year do
they have any help available in seventy
mountains of paperwork to fill out which
I've sold out and sent back and now
they're just kind of in negotiations I
guess they're they're calling me I'm
calling them we're trying to work
something out
and you know they've rolled it down
because that tildes 950 it was
originally 1,100 mm-hmm so they knocked
it down some for me but it's still I
mean I've done 401k loans which I know
you're against loes I've done those to
try and you know help with this and I
kind of don't know what to do you know
I'm you're playing I love the way it
sounds and so like that but like how do
I get started doing this have they don't
they don't until we get the other side
of this right now we're in survival mode
financially and you know because we're
going to take care of your baby that's
your first thing right before anything
else before we worry about my plan you
know so you're you're gonna the first
goal is just to get survival going and
that means being able to buy the
medication and feed your family and keep
your lights on and not lose your house
right right and so we start doing a
budget with that and immediately I went
to if we can cut the cost on the
medication and you're already working on
that I would keep working on that that's
what I would do
so the you know begin to build push that
down and we'll work from there
but the now I think the what I wanted to
just back up and go with what we call
the four walls and that means keep the
four walls of your house standing okay
it starts with food and you make enough
to buy food
okay and by the medication food and then
we're gonna pay the lights and water and
by the medication do you have a mortgage
or rent it's a right - oh okay you pay
that bill
okay so you eat you keep the lights on
you pay the rent so you're not homeless
and you pay the medication okay there's
not gonna be a lot of money left over
after that your wife does your wife does
not work outside the home correct and
and she's got a full-time job taking
care of a little boy with cancer yeah
and so yeah you buy that and you know
other stuff you know stop adding to a
401k stop buying anything or doing
anything if you've got an old student
loan laying around just tell them I'm
not paying it right now good luck
because you got about it so you got to
buy this medication and your food for
your family and that's really all I'm
worrying about now if you can find some
extra money to begin to you know be
current on other things first and then
begin to pay off some of those old debts
while not accruing new ones then that
would be the best case right you'd be
like treading water right if you're
getting further behind I'll accept that
versus not buying his medication right
right we're gonna buy the medication
period then hopefully you're not getting
further behind hopefully you can pick up
some side work or some overtime or
something else to hit cuz $1,000 a month
coming in extra right now is a lot of
money for you yeah that'd be a life
saver yeah
and so I mean you're probably gonna look
at doing that sometime in this journey I
don't know when I mean it depends on how
your son's health is going and how much
time you need to spend there with him I
don't want to take that away but I'm
trying to keep your family from getting
underwater so far that you can't get out
two-and-a-half years from today right
exactly and that's what I've been
looking into and with trips to Iowa City
which is a four-hour drive from
I live at that's just the best doctor
we've been able to find you know it's
hard to find that second job that would
still allow me to do you know to go to
the Iowa City I guess so yeah okay cool
good yeah so so let's kind of lay it out
this way but goal number one is the four
walls and medication you don't I mean
when I say that yeah okay once you've
got that goal number two is to be
current on existing other debts okay
okay then then goal number three will
begin to pay off those debts if you make
enough money to get all the way to goal
number three fine if you don't find
you're gonna break even for a while
until we get the other side of this and
the need for this expensive medication
goes away the medical bills go away and
you can work extra your wife to take
side job you know once this health
returns we can do a lot of stuff to dig
out of this right right but for right
now our goal is to feed your family and
save his life right okay so just like
collections go right in space yeah they
can they can just stand in line outside
the door because I'm not going to pay
them and not buy this medication right
I'm not gonna pay them and let your
lights get cut off exactly
yeah I'm just prioritizing the money
that you do have with those three guards
most important things first next most
important thing and next most important
thing and an unpaid old medical bill is
way down the list of important things
it's not really there it's not even on
the list of important things it's on the
list but it's not important okay we'll
get to it when we get to it now if you
get a $50,000 inheritance check yeah
we'll reach over and start paying some
bills right or you get a new job making
180,000 you know we'll reach over and
start paying some bills right but until
you start making an excess money above
your four walls and staying current
going back on old stuff you don't have
the money to do it okay you'll get there
eventually but for today
we can tread water and take care of his
health that's gonna be our thing so you
call me back if I can help you any
further man appreciate the call